Speaker 1: Newsmax host Greg Kelly has an idea
for unifying the country. Just pardon all the
January six Trump riot defenders. Joe Biden could
really bring everybody together if he just said,
Hey, you know what, we're going to let you
all go. We're going to pardon all of you. Now,
how that would unite the country, I don't know.
But let's listen to what Greg Kelly had to
circle opponents, political enemies in jail.
Speaker 3: You know, if he wanted to unify
this country on January.
Speaker 1: 21st after.
Speaker 3: He made that solemn pledge,
his whole soul was in it to unify us.
Speaker 1: He could have gone to that jail
and made arrangements for.
Speaker 3: Them.
Speaker 1: To be let go. How would that even
unify the country? Like most of the country,
it's shocking that the country's
ever really united on anything. But
most of the country is already united that
the riots were bad. It was Trumpists who did
it. The perpetrators should be prosecuted. So how
would saying, we're going to let all you guys go,
how would that unite the country? It seems it
would be an incredibly dumb thing to do. Maybe
he meant instead of unifying, this is how to
capitulate to the extreme right. Just let all
of them go. And meanwhile, remember that they
preach personal responsibility and all of it.
They say we have to be responsible for our
actions. We have to take seriously when we make
a decision. We have ultimate agency. We are the
ultimate agents of our lives. And sometimes those
actions come with consequences. But actually, the
president should just let all of us go. What and
the other kind of layer to this that's weird.
And I don't expect a host on Newsmax to really
understand this or take it seriously anyway, is if
they did nothing wrong, as is another narrative.
Then why would they need to be pardoned if they
didn't do anything wrong? They'll just be found
not guilty. They will never stop claiming that the
other side needs to do something. What about not
rioting? What about that? As a way to stay out
of trouble, don't riot to begin with. And then
you wouldn't have this problem in from the get go.
They. Every principle that they claim to espouse
goes in the third element of the bathroom. The
toilet. As soon as it's inconvenient. And now it's
personal responsibility. Well, all of a sudden,
it's up to Biden. It's up for whoever to give them
these. Get out, quite literally, get out of jail
free card. Not going to happen. And it actually
wouldn't unify the country. It would do the
opposite because most of the country, shockingly,
actually thinks these rioters did do something
wrong and they need to be held accountable